que ce soit les surligneurs pour la
terminale l'agenda pour le collège ou
tout simplement le choix du cahier pour
l'année scolaire l'achat des fournitures
est un moment particulier à l'heure de
la rentrée
parents et enfants doivent parfois
régler des équations surprise moi je
suis en temps de choisir une
calculatrice sachant que le lycée m'a
donné le choix entre deux et je découvre
avec stupéfaction qui a 25 euros d'écart
entre les deux donc à prêter je vais
regarder
qu'est ce que je peux avoir de plus ou
de moins pour 25 euros 25 euros qui
peuvent peser cher cette année le panier
moyen des fournitures scolaires et de 82
euros pour le cours préparatoire 186e
est un peu moins de 200 euros pour
l'entrée au lycée des sommes
conséquentes qu'il faut budgétisé juste
après les vacances a alors les plaisirs
non non pas de plaisir non non non parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens
j'essaye de faire moitié moitié c'est à
dire lui faire apprendre des choses qui
sont suffisamment fantaisistes pour lui
faire plaisir tout en n'étant pas les
plus chers pour pouvoir épargner mon
budget du côté des distributeurs aussi
cette dernière ligne droite de la
rentrée est un moment crucial
cette enseigne spécialisée dans la vente
de fournitures scolaires réalise 20% de
son chiffre d'affaires entre mi-août et
fin septembre habituellement au long de
l'année avec nos professionnels ou
particuliers ont fait environ 250 300
clients par jour donc on double activité
durant la période des classes ont
recruté en fonction on prend 2,3
personnes supplémentaires pour le
magasin notamment pour réaliser l'équipe
de rentrée des classes que les gens
déposent viennent chercher deux heures
après et pour assurer surtout en caisse
pour que le volume puisse puisse passer
facilement et la course dans les rayons
ne devrait pas s'arrêter cette semaine
avec les deux mondes de matériel qui
varient en fonction des professeurs et
des matières